so earlier this week we were talking
about Donald Trump's medical letter and
totally offhandedly I did like a
5-second Alex Jones impression from
Infowars I didn't plan it it just
happened and people are really reacting
to it very very strongly so let me just
replay it for you to see so we're all on
the same page to begin with I hope
people realize in the midst of the
insane conspiracy theories about oh if
you watch Alex Jones there's a Secret
Service agent who's walking around with
a with an injector to inject Hillary
Clinton with some I don't even know what
the hypothesis is we have a letter so I
did I didn't think this was really any
big deal and to be honest I think it's a
terrible Alex Jones impression but we
received so many comments about it that
I'll put some up on the screen for you
to take a look at one who said that Alex
Jones impression was hilarious so out of
character another comment didn't think
David was capable of that LMAO at
David's Alex Jones impression Andrew
said that Alex Jones impression was
absolutely awesome lmao
Rowland said that's an amazing Alex
Jones impression Nicki saying that
impression was pretty funny and Tom's
saying please please do more Alex Jones
impersonations on the show I would like
to develop it more I'm just terrible at
impressions you know I try to pick up on
some element of the voice like he has
this suit like it's a it's not a listen
but it's a slight slight slight Lisp
type thing and you can hear it one of
Alex Jones's favorite words is
globalists and the way he says it is
more like globalist there's a slight
Lisp there and then it's just kind of
like I don't I don't know if I'd call it
a smoker's voice or what it is I'm going
to work with the following video to
develop my impersonation of Alex Jones
take a look so this is an attack on you
and your family and and and they don't
want you to know they're doing it even
though it's Declassified so what I'm
telling you as a fact it's worse than
I'm saying because there's no way to
describe how horrible this is and how
big this is
and I'll stinking this is I can't tell
you about the matrix you're gonna have
to decide you wanna take the red pill
and see of yourself yeah so I'm gonna
try to start becoming incredibly
conspiratorial sort of in that way but
it'll all be progressive ideas and and
use and Alex Jones
voice I don't know if I can do it but I
think it would be cool if I could get
like one or two impressions in I've just
am terrible at them
I think the Segway is very smoothly into
us into us talking about our new bonus
show content about Chupacabra and the
lizard people yeah and you know the
bonus show has gone completely
conspiratorial now Rachel in case you're
not aware it's basically all vaccines
cause autism we never landed on the moon
building seven george w bush and or the
jews pick whichever one you want does it
even matter did 9/11 so on and so forth
so it's gonna be a real experience for
you today yeah impersonations conspiracy
theories i think we have a real really
good show lined up i don't don't get the
Lochner come on loch ness monster - who
could i remain convinced and I've I
don't think I've told either of you guys
this story before I was at a radio
conference years ago and I was hanging
in a very very small group Alex Jones
was invited to speak and after he spoke
I was in a tiny little group it was me
Alex Jones and the then hosts of a
program called free talk live a
libertarian minded show Marc and Ian
Mark edge and Ian Freeman were we were
just in a little group and I think they
knew Alex Jones already and Alex Jones
alluded to the fact that it's all an act
which is what exactly what I believe I
don't think he thinks any of this stuff
I don't think he believes any of this
stuff I believe he is playing a
character because he came off in a
demeanor that I've never seen of his on
any video ever he said very casually
almost like he was a normal person you
think I freaked them out I really could
have done the full thing but I I sort of
chose not to and just the way he said it
was completely self actualized like this
is a character you know what was his
inflection the same no he did not do the
gotta really freak them out it was not
anything like that it was just really
gonna freak those guys out you know and
and so I remain convinced to this day
that it is all completely concocted and
that this guy is doing this as a
business model and he's doing it for
entertainment value and and it's it's I
that's where I am today on Alex Jones
and a few people have suggested similar
things I kind of think he's talking like
Harry Caray from Center
yeah that is a that is very true it is a
similar sort of like the the
impersonation of Harry Caray no doubt
about it